bonjour Nous partons pour la Brenne ou
le pays dit des mille étangs la Brenne
est en grande partie protégée par le
Parc régional mais il y a aussi d'autres
enjeux notamment la chasse et la déprise
agricole qui font que les paysages
aujourd'hui se transforment
la Brenne résumé la Brenne à ses étangs
serait passé à côté de ses prairies ses
forêts ses bocages et sa friche
grandissante
mais il est vrai que c'est l'action de
l'homme sur ce sol pauvre et humide qui
a créé ce paysage unique de près de 2300
étangs
Alexandre Martin architecte lié au
paysage vit ici depuis 21 ans
là on est vraiment
face à un paysage typique de Braine on a
tous les éléments caractéristiques de la
Brenne à savoir une alternance de bois
et d'étang et la chance qu'on a aussi
c'est d'avoir un site qui est entre tenu
on a encore de la prairie parce que la
tendance actuelle de la Brenne c'est
l'emprichissement et c'est vraiment
le problème d'avenir de ce territoire la
légende raconte qu'au septième siècle
des moines l'idée de creuser des étangs
afin d'assainir les marécages et
produire du poisson dans la réalité
c'est au 12e siècle que l'on commence
une pisciculture de masse dans la Brenne
c'était un moyen pour assainir cette
cette région parce que le rocher est
juste en dessous et donc le lot ne peut
pas être absorbé alors s'il n'y avait
pas des temps on serait dans une zone de
marécage non contrôlé carpe tanche
gardons brochet devienne une des
principales ressources des habitants
aujourd'hui il en est produit un millier
de tonnes par an sur plus de 8500
hectares d'eau
ici l'on dit que toute cette eau ou se
reflète le ciel donne une lumière
particulière aux paysages Jean-Charles
en est tombé amoureux voit la vingt ans
depuis il vit ici les lumières c'est
jamais pareil il y a des lumières tout à
fait particulières tout à fait
extraordinaire il y a aussi parfois
beaucoup de tristesse dans ces paysages
c'est vrai que en hiver c'est pas facile
de d'habiter dans cette région par
contre si on s'est regardé un petit peu
même des paysages dans lesquels on
évolue tous les jours je veux dire c'est
jamais pareil
presque un tiers de la pluviométrie
annuelle
on a une architecture qui est dans son
jus très typique heureusement
le phénomène de ruines a tendance à
s'atténuer ce genre de maison quand
elles sont à vendre trouve en général
preneur en Brenne c'est une région qui
est quand même très prisée à la fois par
la population locale du département de
l'Inde mais aussi par des gens de la
région parisienne donc on assiste de
plus en plus à des restaurations de de
bâti et dans bien des cas c'est d'une
bonne chose comme la Sologne la Brenne a
vu sa terre devenir territoire de chasse
avec l'élevage et la pisciculture elle
est une des principales ressources de la
région du coup elle est autorisée jusque
dans le parc naturel régional
ce sont les sangliers et les cervidés
puis le gibier d'eau qui ont la
préférence des chasseurs au fil du temps
les terres agricoles sont vendus en
territoire de chasse qui retournent à la
Friche c'est la friche alors c'est pas
forcément quelque chose de totalement
négatif parce que le paradoxe de la
Brenne c'est que la friche ça coûte très
cher pour la chasse tout simplement
c'était les terres qui sur le plan
agricole étaient très pauvres et la
chasse les a valorisés mais la chasse se
contente bien souvent de la friche
votre temps s'était cultivé ça voilà
l'évolution
il y avait 400 breviers à pas trop
les agriculteurs ont toujours vécu
difficilement en Brenne et aujourd'hui
compte tenu des du prix des terres il
est très difficile pour des jeunes de
s'installer sachant que ils n'auront pas
de de résultats à la clé donc la
concurrence de la de la chasse et
terriblement brutal
territoire agricole pauvre la Brenne
joue sans doute son avenir dans le
développement des loisirs tels que la
chasse ou le tourisme le prix à payer
une désertification du monde agricole et
la perte de paysages cultivé par la main
de l'homme